and we've developed this framework that
we've placed on our website and we're
talking about it every week here
of how does our culture and values
framework look like in terms of us
combining our passion
with focus on healthcare to drive a
meaningful impact then of course there's
example we explain what does passion
mean for us what does focus mean for us
and what is a meaningful and significant
impact
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthred excel
let's talk about the united states
healthcare system and the rehabilitation
after hospitalization
welcome johnny stein the ceo and founder
of laguna
ioni is a serial entrepreneur who
started his journey as a software
engineer at microsoft having completed
his mba at harvard yoni joined rpx corp
as a founding member of the insurance
business
after rpx went public he only left rpx
to co-fund and merge a fund into
fortress investment group where he spent
six years as an investor he only moved
to israel and launched laguna health a
digital recovery assurance company with
his long-time friend and colleague from
microsoft yael peladadam
joni stein welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you good to be here i'm so
energized by the last 40 minutes of our
conversation i just hope we can capture
part of this excitement you know in
these next 20 minutes what you're
working on is i think one of the most
impactful things that i've heard
honestly the insights that you have into
the us healthcare system you know from
all perspectives from a scientific
perspective from a behavioral
perspective from a macro micro it's just
inspiring and and to think that you've
done all of this
during covet in this last year and and
the meaning that you bring with you to
me as a as an aspiring entrepreneur is
really really inspiring so first of all
thank you already
tell me a little bit about yourself
before we dive into laguna and and what
you're doing today with the u.s
healthcare system
uh super quickly about myself i guess
israeli originally or as i was saying
from kitchen and moldova originally but
then spent 20 years of my life here um
could not avoid technology it was near
and dear to my heart from childhood so
did my undergrad at that then was an
engineer for three years at microsoft
moved to the states for my mba at hbs
moved over to san francisco in 2010 to
join this really interesting patent
startup uh called rpx that went public
which was a fascinating rocket ship to
be a part of then moved over to the
finance world where i spent 70 years at
fortress investing group which is a
large private equity and credit fund
and then due to a family tragedy ended
up returning to israel and really
reorienting on health care we lost my
mother-in-law in 2016 which got my wife
and i thinking about meaning of life and
doing something with deep purpose so
talking about laguna that was kind of my
uh genesis if you will and wake up
moment in terms of doing something that
is meaningful so talking about meaning
nothing more meaningful than life
obviously
your entrance to the u.s healthcare
system you know coming from israel
living in america originally uh
how do you get to be so involved with
such a complicated system when you're
not even a huge part of the system good
question um so first of all i'm
fortunate to have a very
amazing and experienced partner yael
pellet adam the co-founder of laguna uh
who built a company in the space and
brings a lot of credibility and
experience and was certainly a huge
guide in the early days in addition to
that though the system is so fragmented
and complex that whatever head start you
think you have the road you need to
travel is so long and far do you really
have to immerse yourself uh in the early
days of laguna we spoke with
hundreds of people i'm not exaggerating
i um an organized guys i had a crm who
spoke with hundreds of people actually
not just in the states because one of
the early
uh
ideas if you will that we've explored
was more in the space of hospital at
home and israel is actually a global
leader in the space and worked with a
wonderful individual dr rita malhofer
who's a
ceo and now chairman of savage when it's
a known quantity globally in that space
and so we ended up learning not only
about the us but also about other
markets
that to a large extent serve as an
inspiration so what i would say is when
you consider what's broken and how to
fix it you should not only become
extremely smart in digital health and
u.s healthcare ecosystem you have to be
very thoughtful about stakeholder
analysis you also need to draw
inspiration call it from other systems
and how is it done
is it better and is it applicable
in the states
and give me a few key perspectives on on
hospital at home even though that's not
what laguna is doing today but you're
but from the research you've done which
you can't be completely off guard
certainly so as kovit was starring yael
and i realized that you know the world
of hospitalization before and after will
have to be reimagined mind you the early
days of covid folks were being pushed
out of hospitals because hospitals were
trying to free up beds uh
elective surgeries were being canceled
and it was it was easy to see that a new
model will have to take hold and there's
essentially kind of two vectors of of
attack those two ways you either
reimagine the hospital which is
essentially hospital at home how do you
get hospital acute like services to
people's home or after and we in fact
spend the first two months looking at
the before which is the hospital at home
and we've examined systems like israel
like the uk brazil australia australia
is the global leader in that in fact and
and then we understood the extent to
which it is or is not applicable in the
states actually now cms is finally
paying for it mayo clinic invested in
medically home so we're finally seeing
the glaciers so to speak move which is
exciting and amazing because it's better
for the patient it's cheaper it's a
clear win-win
uh so that was kind of how we got
started but we understood that there are
meaningful headwinds there are
meaningful challenges as in hospitals
adoption or willingness to adopt it and
how intertwined the system is and we
understood that actually a much better
strategic wedge is when folks go home
then we can accompany them in the
recovery journey right and so one of the
things that you know that i'm thinking
that coming into this office i'm
thinking to myself okay when you look at
hospitalization and and in general have
the health care system i'm sick i go to
the hospital i get treatment i come home
great blank page the next time great
life happens and something else will
happen that's not actually the case
right so so as it turns out on average
for every day you spend in the hospital
you recover at home a week
the average hospitalization is
approximately 4.3 days which means that
on average people spend a month at home
recovering alone alone exactly and so
there's no hmos like we know here in
israel and the system is quite
fragmented and folks are sent from the
hospital kind of wheeled off usually
across the line and then it's like bye
bye which is tragic because then folks
have to deal with multiple challenges of
recovery the big items will certainly
medication adherence therapy appointment
adherence understanding signs and
symptoms all of that with no help with
no support with nobody to speak to real
but how big can this problem actually be
because you know when somebody's sick
they have surgery they get a treatment
you know obviously they want to keep
track of their medication they want to
they they want to consult with every
little thing but but that's not
generally it's huge so it's a good
question we've done the actuarial work
to really map in fine actuarial detail
what we call patient journey after the
hospital to see how the wake so to speak
of people grows
and in medicare and older population
over half of people escalate from the
home to more acute venues home health
skill nursing facilities or kind of the
the big no more than half more than half
in in
in in in commercial population and
working age sub 65 40 in the year after
the surgery
so so
a good chunk of people and again kind of
the the attention has gone to
readmission but certainly your inability
to stay home that means you are failing
to recover be it you needing external
help via home health services or you
having to go to a skilled nursing
facility or certainly having to go back
to the hospital so this is a big problem
that is costing a lot of dollars to the
pairs and it's certainly tragic to the
patients who have to go through it
especially tragic because half of these
escalations half of these readmissions
are avoidable which is kind of where it
gets interesting so we're looking at
millions of people dozens of
stakeholders hugely complicated system
what can a startup in rahman ghan
do about this problem
good question it is quite complicated
and we're for the first of all we're
startup in ramadan and in the state of
course of course so everything business
and clinical and operational for laguna
from day one is in the states everything
engineering data and product this year
we're actually trying to test the best
best of both worlds the best talent pool
here and there um so
we can do many things and in fact what
we're building at laguna is an engine is
a system that enables us to support
people in a rather sophisticated manner
with what we call kind of the ways of
recovery certainly drawing the analogy
to the navigation software right and the
reason we're using that analogy is
instead of navigating with the map folks
have to navigate the journey of recovery
using a discharge summary which i don't
know how comfortable most people are
with maps but the vast majority are
uncomfortable using a discharge summary
it is often generic it is not written in
plain english to say the least of course
and certainly people's mindset is very
stressful and anxious so it's difficult
to navigate and we're building a system
that helps break it down to individual
steps and also make our coaches
available to you proactively so we
engage with people as they get admitted
to the hospitals and we accompany them
in the months thereafter until they're
back recovered so not only avoiding a
readmission which is a certain arbitrary
if you will line in the sand or really
following through the full process both
with digital support and human support
stakeholders we have to talk about them
why why is this so a win-win alignment
across the various stakeholders walk me
through some of the strategic mindset of
course so so
recovery and readmission avoidance is
one of the rare instances in healthcare
where what's known as the three ps of
healthcare align and agree the three p's
of course are patient provider and payer
and it's it's rare that they agree
because due to the
foundational construct of u.s healthcare
ecosystem there's
constant tension and conflicts of
interest accept recovery and readmission
as patients leave the hospital patients
so certainly motivated to recover and
not come back to the hospital that's
intuitive
payers would rather pay less than more
and would rather for their patients and
members to recover and not go back to
the hospital then they would need to
spend additional 35 000 for the first
month of readmission and providers
meaning the hospitals for the last 10
years since the affordable care act also
known as obamacare have a variety of
carrots and sticks imposed on them by
the centers of medicare and medicaid and
payers in terms of hrp hospital
readmission reduction programs a program
of penalties or medicare star rating or
a variety of risk contracts that make
them care about outcomes from a
financial standpoint so this is a good
instance of finding a problem where you
have a stakeholder alignment around the
problem you're trying to solve
circle back to the idea of meaning
no you you mentioned to me that you work
until 1 am you finish with a smile you
wake up with a smile and you and you go
back to do it again
what is it what does this mean for you
you know i i would say i first
discovered the
joy and importance of meaning in my
military service i spent many years in
special forces and i was fortunate to do
something that i perceived to be quite
important nationally and it and it's
amazing it's hugely motivating and
inspiring and then kind of moving to the
civilian life if you always gave up on
on the hope of finding something
comparable like that
in my career moving from being an
investor to an entrepreneur in digital
health i could not have imagined
this type of important meaning and more
so the extent to which it motivates you
not only to work hard but really to
solve this problem this problem is not
this is not your typical cyber or
enterprise problem you are
foundationally and in our case directly
helping people recover helping people
avoid tragic circumstances
to name a few or dealing with people who
are suicidal we're dealing with people
who are on the ambulance back home and
we help them so it's phenomenal to see
this very direct impact on people's
lives and oh by the way not to mention
the societal and economic benefits but
you are absolutely dealing in something
with direct impact on human lives which
is a beautiful place to be in i would
say and so as the entrepreneur and as a
leader here in this organization as
you're growing this organization you're
moving quickly what do you what do you
rationalize doing as the leader you know
focusing on this on building a culture
where
people that are working with you are
feeling those same strong feelings so so
i would say we're pretty thoughtful on
culture and
to
really distill our culture and values
yale and i very early in laguna really
distilled our values which is very early
usually companies do that years after
being born and we've developed this
framework that we've placed on our
website and we're talking about it every
week here
of how does our culture and values
framework look like in terms of us
combining our passion
with focus on healthcare to drive a
meaningful impact and of course there's
example we explain what does passion
mean for us what does focus mean for us
and what is a meaningful and significant
impact so this is not something that we
just feel this is something that we
communicate to the world and are very
much looking for the talent that this
sense of meaning as we articulated
resonates with and this is something
that we practice in the company and live
by and and so what is a success for you
you know you've had many many successes
what is a success with laguna for you i
think laguna's success is my success
laguna's success would be making a real
dent in people's healthcare and live
after hospitalization as you said and
that is absolutely the case tens of
millions of people go through outpatient
and inpatient hospitalization most of
them go home alone failed to recover it
is traumatic and tragic for these people
and it's extremely painful and costly to
both providers and certainly payers
laguna's success is to help avoid the
unnecessary readmissions about 50 of
these bad outcomes of these readmissions
are avoidable with our interventions of
combining behavioral health care
management and digital and data tools as
we were doing for building it today
avoiding those 50 avoidable readmissions
is a huge success for the system and
huge success for me yoni i think what
you're working on is incredible thank
you for for the time that you're giving
me i know how incredibly busy you are
and i really appreciate it i have a few
last quick questions too and i want to i
want you to take me back to her
childhood before laguna before the army
service before being an investor and
entrepreneur before hbs what really
fascinates you you know your innovation
let's say you're what really what what
drives in your day to day
i said several things um
technology from a kid meant a lot for me
uh that was
my thing as a kid if you will like well
almost completed a computer science
degree as a kid it absolutely serves me
and drives me today and it's amazing for
me to think about the impact that
technology may have on health care uh
number one meaning and inspiration i now
know to kind of distill it and
articulate it because before i would say
it stumbled upon it in the military now
i know that there is a core need for me
and certainly correctabilistic for me
and i would say
energy and passion it's certainly the
case for yale and absolutely the case
with me and laguna now helps me be very
authentic about who i am because it's
certainly very important as a leader in
the entrepreneur to live by your
passions right and you sound very tired
all the time
what inspires you today in the whether
it's in the day-to-day or or something
that you know serves as a constant
inspiration for you i think healthcare
and healthcare entrepreneurs provides a
lot of inspiration for me healthcare as
an industry provides an inspiration
because we're dealing with
one of the most if not the most
important problems and opportunities in
the world which is helping people thrive
number one specifically people who were
successful in this very complicated
industry of u.s digital health and
global healthcare and digital health
that is a huge inspiration for me this
problem has its own kind of domain
challenges and seeing the people who've
been they'll done that and overcame
these challenges serve as a huge
inspiration and you've brought some of
the most amazing ones to be a part of
laguna which is incredible and what are
three words you would use to describe
yourself
energetic it's probably one of them um
optimistic yeah
vocal perhaps
i'll take it
thank you very very much
laguna
it's really amazing thank you for all
the amazing work it's a pleasure
you